bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de reporter sur
France 24 plus de 530 personnes ont été
tuées près de 300 kidnappés par des
gangs depuis janvier en Haïti c'est un
sombre bilan établi par le nu qui
envisage d'ailleurs le déploiement en
urgence de force pour lutter contre
l'extrême violence qui frappe le pays la
guerre des gangs fera et l'État perdent
de plus en plus le contrôle du
territoire haïtien pour preuve se
reportage que vous allez voir a été
tourné en janvier par les équipes de
France 24 en espagnol a Port-au-Prince
sa capitale aujourd'hui tomber aux mains
de groupe armés les plaies d'Haïti un
reportage de nos équipes de Bogota
Margot loisillon Herminia Fernandez
Sandrine exil et ma théorie das
[Musique]
retour à la case départ ce dimanche
matin des dizaines Tahitiens reviennent
à Port-au-Prince après avoir tenté de se
rendre aux États-Unis à bord d'un bateau
de fortune leur embarcation a été
interceptée
dans notre pays mais malheureusement
mauvais temps
et la situation nous nous fait de fautes
d'accord
nous passerons à retourner là-bas parce
que et ici nous travaillons nous ne
travaille pas il y a un problème en
sécurité
désorienter et sans destination précise
une seule certitude pour ces hommes et
ces femmes il va falloir de nouveau
faire face à la dure réalité
Jésus mène partirait si elle le pouvait
cette mère célibataire vit dans une
pièce de 16 mètres carrés avec ses trois
enfants et deux autres membres de sa
famille elle est ce qu'on appelle une
déplacée interne
elle a dû fuir son quartier en proie à
la violence
hier je parlais avec mon frère aîné qui
me disait que l'on vit dans l'angoisse
qu'il dort angoissé à cause des coups de
feu des gangs du fait qu'ils ont dans
les maisons la nuit dernière l'angoisse
l'a empêché de dormir
on ne vit pas réellement on n'a pas de
vie
Jésus mène travaille comme employé dans
une famille de Port-au-Prince et a
parfois du mal à nourrir ses enfants
elles se sont plus en sécurité dans ce
nouveau quartier mais s'inquiète
toujours pour l'avenir de sa famille
les enfants aimer leur ancien quartier
il l'aimait beaucoup
je sais pas si en grandissant ils
voudront quitter le pays
je ne vois pas très bien qu'elle va être
leur avenir
[Musique]
aujourd'hui j'ai du riz blanc du riz au
haricots une sauce aux haricots rouges
et des légumes
Daddy est également mère célibataire
elle prépare et vend ses repas dans la
rue sa lutte dans un pays où les emplois
sont rares et de garder à flot son
négoce elle confie être proche de la
faillite
c'est compliqué d'investir dans un
commerce beaucoup d'argent se perd
par exemple ce riz est très difficile à
trouver en ce moment et il est très cher
personne n'a les moyens de consommer
même les produits les plus simples je
prépare des repas mais il y a peu de
gens qui viennent acheter je vends très
peu
en Haïti tous les aliments sont importés
alors que le salaire minimum est
d'environ 100 dollars par mois
l'inflation a atteint 49,3% en janvier
presque la moitié du pays souffre
d'insécurité alimentaire aiguë selon le
Programme Alimentaire Mondial des
Nations Unies
Jean-Marc est à la tête d'une entreprise
qui importe des aliments pour tout le
pays et emploie environ 600 personnes
cela fait plus de 30 ans que ce
franco-marocain vit en Haïti et il a dû
s'adapter à la crise aujourd'hui le gros
de son commerce est l'importation de
poulet mais il a également une ligne de
produits plus fin avec lesquelles il
approvisionne ses restaurants dans la
capitale
qui vient de Norvège
et ça c'est du saumon frais des filets
de saumon frais
que nous servons dans tous nos
restaurants et envelopper les trucs du
Cap mettre du plastique et tout tu
embauches tout cette entrepreneur est
pessimiste sur l'avenir économique de
l'île la provisionnement en essence la
corruption des douanes l'insécurité il
doit faire face à de nombreuses
difficultés il y a aucune entreprise qui
va vouloir investir en Haïti il y a
simplement les entreprises qui sont ici
à l'heure actuelle qui essaient de
survivre et de payer leurs frais c'est
tout mais au niveau nourriture quoi
qu'il arrive il faudra toujours donner
de la nourriture à ces gens
Marc pense à prendre sa retraite la
situation est devenue ingérable
on a peut-être 30 camions mais là on a
chaque fois les points de camions on
doit les faire escortés par de la police
depuis quelques mois Jean-Marc vit au
milieu de son entrepôt il préfère éviter
tout déplacement en dehors de la
forteresse qu'il adressait
d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir là le mur ce
mur ça fait tout le tour de la propriété
comme vous pouvez voir c'est de la
sécurité armée de nuit de jour et j'ai
des chiens et des chiens d'attaque que
je fais sortir la nuit
Haïti est considéré comme l'un des pays
les plus dangereux au monde plus de 600
000 armes légales et illégales seraient
en circulation dans cette nation peuplée
d'un peu moins de 12 millions
d'habitants une centaine de gangs
consolide jour après jour leur emprise
sur la capitale ils affrontent une
police fragile et sous équipée la
dernière semaine de janvier 18 policiers
ont été tués lors de différents
affrontements un commissaire de la
police nationale haïtienne nous
renseigne sur les conditions précaires
dans lesquelles il travaille sous
couvert d'anonymes
de
pénétrer ça ne pas avoir blindé il nous
faut des moyens les équipements des
véhicules capables de
vlogs beaucoup de dispositions à acheter
l'élevageons pas d'autres espaces ok qui
sont jusqu'à présent
avec les gangs mais la loi du silence
règne et la population civile reste la
principale victime de cette guerre de
territoire
cet hôpital de l’organisation Médecin
sans Frontières et spécialisée en
traumatologie et brûlure
l'homme qui arrive ce matin a été
attaqué à la machette en sortant de chez
lui les raisons de l'agression sont
floues comme souvent
de la région
du monde supérieur gauche avec
notion de bassonade associés
James et chirurgien pour lui pas besoin
d'opérer le patient mais il va falloir
refermer les plaies profondes en 3 ans
de service dans cet hôpital le médecin a
vu défiler toutes sortes de patients et
de drames
assez souvent c'est des personnes qui
habitent comme dans des hommes et que il
y a des conflits entre deux canaux c'est
des dommages collatéraux ou des membres
de gants qui vont arriver pour certains
cas
l'hôpital reçoit également des
accidentés de la route ou des victimes
de chutes mais les blessés par balle
représentent 70% de son activité une
situation qui semble empirer ces
derniers mois
avant les traumatismes c'était surtout
des balles de petits calibres donc à
faible vélosité donc de nos jours ça a
tendance à augmenter puisque les
patients qu'on reçoit qui sont des
accidents par balles c'est des balles de
grosses de gros calibre qui laisse des
plaies assez importantes et dont la
prise en charge et se fait sur une
beaucoup plus longue période que ce
qu'on avait avant
dans l'une des chambres un homme est
hospitalisé depuis quatre jours il a
voulu éviter le barrage installé par les
délinquants armés qui tiennent le
quartier où il vit
les bandits ont commencé à m'interroger
l'un de m'a dit je vais te tirer dessus
et l'autre m'a dit est-ce qu'elle a le
mur
alors j'ai décidé de faire ce qu'il
disait
quand je suis arrivé en haut du mur l'un
d'entre eux m'a dit si tu ne veux pas
que je te tire dessus saute de l'autre
côté quand j'ai sauté je suis tombé dans
un abîme inimaginable j'ai simplement
entendu que mes deux jambes se brisaient
la violence de ces gangs semble n'avoir
aucune limite il contrôle aujourd'hui
plus de 60% du territoire de la capitale
depuis le siège de l'ONG le chef de
mission de Médecins sans frontières
reconnaît que cette expansion rapide des
groupes armés perturbe les opérations de
ses hôpitaux
c'est la clinique dont on a interrompu
le support la semaine dernière suite à
l'intrusion dorme armée qui sont venus
se saisir d'un patient pour l'exécuter à
l'extérieur de l'hôpital
ici là le point jaune sur cette carte en
rouge les zones de la ville entièrement
contrôlées par les gangs en blanc les
sols dans lesquels nous avons pu nous
déplacer pour la réalisation de ce
reportage
ce matin-là l'ambiance est lourde dans
le studio de radio ou l'écrivain Lionel
Trouillot anime chaque semaine un
programme sur la vie culturelle du pays
personnellement il y a eu la
séquestration de mon meilleur ami Pierre
Bitou
qui a été libéré par ces ravisseurs hier
soir quand nous sommes importante et
puis il y a ce matin le fait que les
bandits sont entrés
lourdement sont entrés dans une école
ils ont réclamé de l'argent les
enlèvements font partie de la vie
quotidienne de Port-au-Prince c'est la
principale source de financement pour
les gangs notamment pour
s'approvisionner en arme chaque jour il
y a au moins deux ou trois prises
d'otages comment peut-on être
aujourd'hui une jeune femme dans le
milieu artistique haïtien tenant compte
de tous les systèmes qui se perpétuent
de domination
ce jour-là Lionel et ses invités
discutent de la place de la femme dans
le monde artistique haïtien une double
problématique dans un pays où la vie
culturelle a presque disparu et où les
chiffres d'agression contre les femmes
ne cessent de croître
c'est fondamental qu'on est
ce genre d'émissions parce que la
circule véritablement le discours
haïtien sur ce que nous voulons faire de
ce pays il y a ce gouvernement qu'on a
du mal à appeler un gouvernement qui met
aucune légitimité et ne pouvant
convaincre personne en Haïti a besoin
d'une force étrangère pour venir
légitimer son existence
le gouvernement dont parle le Lionel et
celui d'Arielle Henry nommé Premier
ministre par le président jovenel Moïse
deux jours avant son assassinat en
juillet 2021 son administration assure
depuis l'intérêt Henri souffre d'un
profond déficit de popularité au sein de
son pays il est accusé d'être à la seule
de des États-Unis et favorable à une
intervention étrangère qui repousserait
la tenue de nouvelles élections une
façon pour lui de garder le pouvoir Jean
Renel c'est nathus ancien sénateur a
monté son propre parti politique il y a
deux ans et dénonce la disparition de la
vie politique de l'île les derniers
scrutins remontent à 2016 et depuis
janvier le pays n'a plus aucun élu
national ni local aujourd'hui on est
censés diriger politiquement par un
gouvernement défacto
gouvernement qui est frappé par un
déficit de légitimité et de l'égalité
aucune institution ne fonctionne
actuellement et autant que les sécurités
de ces gouvernants pour avoir des
élections crédibles la première attente
à laquelle il faut répondre c'est la
question de la sécurité
nous retrouvons Lionel Trouillot qui
tous les jeudis après midi dirige un
atelier d'écriture au cours duquel les
participants discutent de littérature et
de ce qu'ils vivent au jour le jour
tous écrivent des textes que ce soit
dans la presse locale ou pour des
maisons d'édition principale inspiration
pour ces artistes la vie quotidienne
on a été dans la réalité haïtienne dans
ce cas là qui n'acceptable et aussi
dans le rêve de pouvoir la changer
mais beaucoup ne veulent plus attendre
que le rêve devienne réalité les bureaux
de migration croulent sous les demandes
de certains citoyens qui tentent
d'obtenir un passeport depuis janvier le
président américain Joe Biden a inclu
les Haïtiens dans un programme pour
entrer légalement aux États-Unis
certains ne croient plus à une possible
amélioration du pays comme ce jeune
homme qui accepte de nous parler à
visage couvert
Haïti est un enfer en ce moment
partout vous trouvez une cellule de gang
et c'est comme si nous étions enfermés
dans une prison on ne peut rien faire
mais nous n'avons pas besoin d'une armée
de tank de type ou de marine ce qui
viennent ici
non nous ne voulons pas de ce bordel
fuir ou rester une intervention
étrangère aura-t-elle lieu des élections
pourront-elles s'organiser l'avenir du
pays n'a jamais été si incertain l'ONU a
récemment sonné la larme face à une
situation qui se détériore de jour en
jour et implorer kaiti ne devienne pas
une crise oubliée
voilà pour ce reportage que vous pourrez
retrouver sur notre site internet france
24.com merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
et à la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]